I want to have with you today what I
hope will be an adult conversation a
serious conversation and it's a
conversation where I want to put aside
sort of the partisan politics of
evaluating how the current
administration is faring it's a separate
discussion from any particular political
issue it's a separate discussion from
the perception of Donald Trump
internationally which happens to be very
embarrassing but that's not what I
actually want to talk about today we
have to start really thinking about the
Trump mental health concerns that are
increasingly prevalent and a topic of
discussion we did a number of interviews
over the last year and a half sort of
generally about this we did an interview
about Donald Trump's mental health
deteriorating with dr. John Gartner we
did really that interview got more than
half a million views clearly a topic
that resonated with a lot of people we
did another interview where we had a
psychiatrist indicating that actually
Donald Trump's mental condition is
dangerous we did an interview where the
focus was on the impact of Donald
Trump's narcissism and how that presents
a danger in terms of thinking about his
role as president of the United States
and this is a serious enough issue where
every time we talk about it more and
more mental health professionals get in
touch with me and they say yeah David
you really need to keep talking about
this so we're actually working on
getting dr. John Gartner back on the
program because unfortunately and I do
say this seriously I'm honest when I say
it's unfortunate there's evidence that
this is getting worse and Twitter last
night another indication of the
instability I don't know if we we say
it's it's mental illness or cognitive
decline but it's certainly the erratic
emotional instability of the president
not lashing out in a series of tweets
and retweets targeting even relatively
unimportant people in the grand scheme
of things for example Tom Steyer a rich
dude who's been talking about impeaching
Donald Trump for a while
nice guy I'm sure sick
cessful in his career but in the grand
scheme of things it's not super clear
why Donald Trump cares that much about
Tom Steyer Donald Trump last night
tweeting quote weirdo Tom Styer doesn't
have the guts or money to run for
president he's all talk
behavior very unbecoming of the
President of the United States of
America Donald Trump also last night
retweeting an article from the
Washington Examiner a just totally
outrageous right-wing publication it was
Don
it was a Donald Trump jr. post which
Donald Trump retweeted and once again
the Jim Jordan the guy who is quoted in
the article a completely disgraced and
not credible extremist right-wing
Republican and again why is Donald Trump
doing this why is this what he's
spending his time doing we don't know
then
retweeting Don Junior's post of an
article from the straight-up conspiracy
website Zero Hedge suggesting a
conspiracy about British intelligence
officer former British intelligence
officer Christopher Steele who you might
remember was the researcher on the Trump
Russia dossier another Trump enemy and
then tweeting about a dude named Hans
von Spakovsky from the right-wing
Heritage Foundation known for his
efforts to suppress voting via all sorts
of voter ID and other rules that he
supported his dad happens to be Russian
doesn't seem particularly relevant to
our conversation today Donald Trump
they're tweeting that Hans von Spakovsky
has said he's not seen evidence that
Donald Trump has violated the law and
suggesting that Adam Schiff is like a
modern-day Joseph McCarthy of course
Adam Schiff the Democrat in charge of
the House Intelligence Committee this is
not the pattern of someone who is
thinking clearly this is not a rational
person under any circumstances but this
is no random Twitter troll right this is
the President of the United States is he
taking
on the behavior of a trapped rat trying
to figure out whether to abandon ship
and drown in the ocean or wait it out
and ultimately go down with the ship and
that that is where increasingly my
attention is going this noose of
criminality is closing around Donald
Trump 2/3 of Americans now believe that
Donald Trump is a criminal I'll get to
that polling data momentarily and Trump
is now straight up doing his Richard
Nixon I am NOT a crook tweeting just a
couple of days ago quote I am an
innocent man being persecuted by some
very bad conflicted and corrupt people
you know witch-hunt that is illegal and
should never have been allowed to start
and only because I won the election
despite this great success innocent
people normally welcome investigations
that will clear them innocent people
want investigations that will clear them
to be carried out without interference
and without obstruction so that they can
be cleared they don't do everything
under the Sun including committing more
crimes to stop those investigations this
is not the behavior of an innocent
person but more importantly this is not
the behavior of a mentally healthy or
stable person and we're going to be
talking to dr. John Gartner about this
again coming up pretty soon